thank you sherry pornwa skincare is back
and making sure our skin is ready for
the holidays in the desert
and in a mask take a look uli welcome
back
so good to be back rocky it's been a
while because you guys were sold out
which is not a bad problem to have i
feel like vegas bought up everything we
love you guys so much
um so let's talk about obviously it's
the holiday season now
and poor moth skin care makes the
perfect gift
yes i always show my hands first on this
hand i use climate smart skincare
and on the other hand just a regular
moisturizer and rocky look at that
difference
and you know what's different this year
we have to wear masks during the
holidays
and you guys have an answer for that as
well we actually have a special mask
called the smart mask
and we put a mask chain on it so it's
like a
stylish security guard for your mask but
rocky let me tell you about our smart
mask because
everybody is breaking out from wearing a
mask it's called musk knee
even people who never had any kind of
breakouts find themselves with some kind
of a rash or
you know a pimple so what we did is we
used a different fabric
these are three layers of an advanced
moisture control
fabric why so that that moisture that
you breathe out
doesn't get stuck in your mask anymore
so no breathing ground for bacteria
problem solved and it's called the
holiday gift of youth which sounds
amazing what do you get in the gift
well we packed everything in you need
for useful beautiful skin
right now this winter in las vegas
so of course our smart mask with the
beautiful stylish
mess chain is in the gift we have also
our jasmine
flower mask and this is a new mask that
helps you with all this harmful blue
light that is coming out of all the
screens we are so much more in 2020
exposed that's how we communicate now so
this is your antitote that it doesn't
eat you anymore it's our iconic
dessert day cream this is the anti-aging
moisturizer
for your zip code this keeps your skin
hydrated and beautiful
in the desert when you get the few moon
soon days where it's going to be a
little bit cooler
a little bit more humidity in the air
you rotate
to the temperate day cream and then
that's the magic
you dress your skin like you dress
yourself the desert day cream or the
temperate day cream
and then at night rocky you use our
night cream our luxurious night cream
that aligns with the repair and renewal
process during the night and all of it
all these five skincare products are in
this beautiful
luxurious kit it comes also with this
vegan leather bag it has like a little
keychain removable keychain on it with
snowflakes i put it on my car keys it's
wonderful
all of it made in france all clean
ingredient
and instead of 215 dollars just 99
for more information call 909 243-1459
or just visit poormothskincare.com
las vegas and again their special
holiday offer purchase the 215 dollar
gift
gift of youth set for just 99
and that's offer it's good till december
2nd